مرحبا بك معنا اذا ماذا تعني حاله التاهب
الجوي هذه التي اعلنت بالنظر الى ما ذكر
في الاخبار عن حجم وطبيعه القذائف التي
تطلق والمقاطعات التي يجري فيها هذا القصف
نعم محمد بدايه الان في هذه الاثناء تعيش
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف ومختلف المناطق
الاوكرانيه من الغرب وحتى اقصى الشرق حاله
تاهب جوي جديده اعلنت قبل دقائق من الان
وذلك بعد هجمه لليه
بالصواريخ والمسيرات استهدفت
مناطق مختلفه بدايه هنا العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف شهدت ما وصفه عمده كييف
بانه الهجوم الاوسع بالمسيرات منذ بدايه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا قال ان 60
مسيره اطلقت باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه 36
منها اطلقت باتجاه العاصمه كييف وادت الى
اصابات في اكثر من مكان واضرار ماديه
نشاهد هنا في هذا الحي حيثين هذه الضربه
التي تعرضت لها هذا المبنى الشاهق هنا في
الحي الواقع غربي العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
نشاهد اثار
الاستهداف بطائره مسيره تقول الاداره
العسكريه انها من طراز شاهد
وتؤكد ان الدفاعات الجويه استطاعت ان
تقوم بالتعامل مع الطائرات السته وثلاثين
التي وجهت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
لكن حطام هذه الطائرات وبقايا هذه
الطائرات هو ما سقط على هذه المباني لكننا
نشاهد هنا هذه الضربه التي تبدو انها
اصابه باحدى المسيرات بشكل واضح في هذا
المبنى
وليس هذا المكان هو المكان فقط الذي
الوحيد الذي تعرضت له منطقه كييف لاضرار
هذا المشهد ايضا
يتشابه مع مشهد اخر في حي
سلوميانسكي وهناك ايضا يقع المطار
العاصمه وقد ايضا اعلنت الاداره العسكريه
ان حطام احدى المسيرات وصل الى ذاك المطار
وتعرض المدرج تحديدا
لاثار الضرر والقصف نظرا لسقوط حطام احدى
المسيرات هناك وكذلك ايضا في حي شفشانكافا
بالقرب ايضا من وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كان هناك ايضا اضرار وحرائق للسيارات
واضرار في عدد من المباني اجمالي الاصابات
حتى هذه اللحظه هو خمس اصابات
لمدنيين كما اعلنت الاداره العسكريه هنا
وهذه الضربه بالمسيرات كانت قد شهدتها
كييف خلال الليله الماضيه وكان وكنا نلاحظ
ونشاهد تعامل الدفاعات الجويه طيله الليل
مع هذه المسيرات وهم ادى الى سماع ذوي
انفجارات
سلسله من الانفجارات طيله الليله الفائته
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف شكرا لك يا
حسان مسعود منكيف